[Musique]
Avatar Frontiers of Pandora est une
expérience passionnante d'action et d'aventure en monde ouvert. En y jouant sur PC, vous
profiterez de fonctionnalités de pointe qui
vous plongeront dans les merveilles et les
dangers de
[Musique]
Pandora, vous êtes nouveau.  vous n'êtes pas dans ce
monde
Les réflexions et les ombres Ray Trace
amèneront le monde à un tout nouveau niveau de
beauté et de
réalisme. Prévisualisez et affinez vos
performances pour des visuels époustouflants avec
des paramètres graphiques étendus et avec nos
outils PC Benchmark intégrés, les joueurs peuvent
tester leur  paramètres dans un
environnement contrôlé pour comparer les résultats et
optimiser leur
expérience. AMD FSR 2 peut également être utilisé pour
affiner l'équilibre entre
la qualité visuelle et les performances. Le jeu peut
gérer la plupart des résolutions et des
formats d'image, même les écrans ultra larges sont des
configurations de moniteur multim haute résolution que nous
devons  apportez-leur le combat,
les joueurs peuvent profiter d'une
expérience fluide, d'un FPS stable et d'une faible latence dans
toutes les résolutions, ils peuvent même s'attendre à une
fréquence d'images plus élevée avec les bons
paramètres dans le dernier matériel, le jeu
tire parti des processeurs à nombre de cœurs élevé,
car il a été optimisé
fonctionnent aussi bien sur des spécifications inférieures que sur des PC haut de gamme
avec ses nombreuses autres options et
fonctionnalités mises en œuvre. AMD et Ubisoft
repoussent les limites de la qualité technique et
visuelle dans les jeux. La lutte pour
Pandora n'a jamais été aussi captivante.
Plongez-vous dans le
monde extraordinaire des frontières d'Avatar.  de Pandora sur
[Musique]
PC
oh